自己挺能吃苦的，
咱们做保洁这么辛苦的工作，
你一个月还能挣1万多块钱，
你自己挺能吃苦的，
其实我觉得女人啊，
有一把子好力气，
有一把子好身体，
自己能吃苦能挣钱的话，
只要这个男的不拖后腿，
只要这个男的不捅窟窿，
日子总归越过越好的。
一年33岁，
我是就是农村来深圳做保洁的，
刚来一年，
学历能高，
嗯，
大概收入现在是9000~1万之间，
我是二婚，
我和前夫有个儿子，
和现任老公有一个女儿，
但是抚养权不归我，
但是我和产权也很好，
和前夫家关系也还不错哈，
我女儿现在是两岁，
就目前我这个婆婆在带，
然后我们关系也挺好的，
她对我女儿也挺好，
想让你帮我判断一下，
后面我们还没有说继续在一起的那种可能啊，
但和我一样大，
但是我老公呢，
很平庸吧，
真的形容，
因为他思想不太成熟，
性格稍微有点极端，
但是目前这一年多来是有很大改善的，
但是我们目前是低调，
因为他也需要去挣钱，
他收入也是不太稳定，
差不多平均七八千吧一个月，
我们名下也欠一下30万，
我们农村嘛，
有自建房，
但是那个也值不了几个钱哈啊，
然后我们也有名下也有辆车。
也是家用的，
最以关键问题就是要出债，
这30万上我们感觉压力很大，
我其实心态还挺好，
我也愿意跟我老公一起，
我们两个努力一下，
慢慢的偿还。
我现在的工资基本上就是用来打给我婆婆一部分力，
他帮我带孩子，
其实我挺感谢他的啊，
还有我的这边的房租呀，
日唱开销，
孩子的奶粉，
尿不湿，
等于说生活和家庭开销全部是由我来承担的，
他了工资后把这些一付，
然后除掉生活费，
我啥也没有了，
然后我就焦虑的是长此以往就看不到未来，
我老公那不太上进那种类型，
就是他没什么大的想法，
对他的收入吧，
他也虽然有觉得说是不知足不满足的那种状态，
但是他也找不到其他好一点的那种适合他的出入啊，
也可能跟学历啊，
能力啊这些有关哈，
因为债务压力大嘛，
然后他以前还有过那种跟我吵架摔过手机啊，
他就是还挺暴躁的，
可能他也慢慢的觉得孩子大一点，
在这方面也帮助了他不少哈，
然后也平静下来一点，
还有一点呢，
就是我的公公因为前几年投资那个养猪场哈，
然后也亏损了很多，
目前好像他名下欠债四五十万吧，
我具体我也不太清楚，
因为我公公的这部分。
现在又导致就是我老公心里面又要想帮他的爸爸还这一部分，
在我日常生活当中，
他也帮扶不了多少，
现实中他的收入低嘛，
他一边都顾不上，
所以就是很纠结他，
他每天呢，
就会觉得，
哎呀，
我现在收入这么少，
我也想提高一下，
但是我现在找不到出路，
表面上我没有给他施加很大压力啊，
但是在我心里面，
其实我也在慢慢的有点自私点嘛，
就是还要衡量一下我这个老公到底值不值得我跟他，
然后继续维持这个婚姻，
还有就算我们俩如果以后不在一起过了，
现在要如何能够一攒点私房钱呀，
我问你啊，
你们两口子为什么欠30万的债啊？
一个是因为我们俩刚结婚那会儿是没什么钱，
然后他借了10万块钱，
能做一些筹备，
婚礼啊，
彩礼啊，
还有就是这些日常的费用，
再一个就是因为买车，
我做完手付之后，
剩下的用于还这个车贷，
你们俩又不住在一起，
这个车谁在开啊，
目前是她在开，
因为我怀我女儿的时候是胎盘前置，
所以大家需要休养，
然后于我们去产检呀，
因为我们在农村嘛，
去镇上呀，
这些来回平时用到的资率比较大，
所以我也没有怪他啊，
也是因为自己没有好好的规划，
所以当时现在这个状态。
既也变然成为了我们的共同债务，
所以我也没有说是不愿意一去还哈，
我也经济的在挣钱，
但是这个还债的这个过程压力很大，
就是感觉自己收入又少，
然后经济压力又那么大，
要还个两年多三年他也没多，
我觉得这个事情是这样的啊，
你老公现在也能挣七八千块钱一个月，
现在这个阶段的话，
既然是还债的阶段，
大家都是勒紧裤腰带过日子，
那这个钱我就要管起来，
就是让他挣的对拿到我手上，
对具体怎么还，
我对我来规划，
如果说是我一分也拿不到他的，
我就得要，
就得摁头要，
就得把这个财务管起来，
两口子加起来一年是能挣个小20万的，
刨出去开销的话，
两口子加起来可能能存个十几万，
那两三年也这债务也就还清了，
这日子也就有奔头了，
因为你现在这个状态，
坦率的说啊，
如果我自己学历又不是很高，
我现在拖着两婚两孩，
是不是我两次婚姻两个孩子了，
你说我再离异，
我再接，
那难度系数也挺大，
你说我还能少一个什么样的，
那就是把他的财务管起来，
有些东西啊，
不要打肿脸充胖子，
坦率的说，
就你俩这经济条件，
车该卖就卖了，
就不要打肿脸充胖子啊，
是不是能变现的都变现了，
把债务先还上。
至于说他就是你公公的债务的话，
我跟你说，
你们千万别沾手，
你公公的债务就是他的事人。
债难啊，
因为我老公有点遗孝嘛，
我听得出来她你必须把这个钱还起来，
必须把你们身上的债务先处理掉，
这日子才有奔头。
我婆婆现在嗯，
很尽心的在帮我带孩子，
当然我经济上也不亏待他哈，
我觉得这个事情丑话得说在前面，
我要是你的话，
我就是妈，
我们确实现在还有30多万的债务，
你帮我带孩子带的这么辛苦，
我心里是感激你的，
但是呢，
咱们一家人不说两家话，
现在我们首要任务是得把这个债务还完，
等把这个债务还完了，
我肯定孝敬你，
一个月不管是一千两千的，
只要我有，
我肯定得孝敬你，
就得当面说，
就得一家子勒紧裤腰带，
一家子劲儿往一块儿使，
先把债还完了再说，
别打肿点穿胖子了啊，
知道知道，
那其实我公公的债务，
其实后面的话还完我们的，
我们也可以不管是吧，
不管你们没有这个能力，
那其实我跟我老公之间也还能能不到一块吃啊，
这两三年债还完了，
孩子慢慢也大了，
是不是我感觉你也再考个什么育儿嫂的证啊，
什么考个育婴师的证啊，
是不是挣得比现在要多一点儿，
我也没有说是责怪他啊，
就是不知道未来在哪里，
就是有点迷茫，
因为我其实也想找个人倾诉一下，
就是童年也很不幸，
也没有什么家人的帮助呀，
或者是一些比较好的建议啊，
所以每一步都是。
走的好像是乱七八糟的，
你自己挺能吃苦的，
咱们做保洁这么辛苦的工作，
你一个月还能挣1万多块钱，
你自己挺能吃苦的，
其实我觉得女人啊，
有一把子好力气，
有一把子好身体，
自己能吃苦能挣钱的话，
只要这个男的不拖后腿，
只要这个男的不捅窟窿，
日子总归越过越好的，
好好有你这个计划，
其实我也就心里面就知道自己未来需要做点什么了，
哈，
那就这样了，
我也没有什么事，
拜拜，
好拜拜，
嗯，
其实我内心我非常欣赏和尊重这样的女性，
包括给我家里面做育儿嫂的姐姐，
包括以前就在家里面做饭打扫卫生的姐姐，
我真的发自内心的对这些姐姐有一份尊重，
在我感觉女性啊，
可能是因为我妈妈在养育我的过程当中，
也给别人当过家政啊，
也给别人家里面做过饭，
打扫过卫生，
当过阿姨，
我感觉作为女性，
她凭借自己的劳动，
凭借自己的双手去创造财富，
去养活自己，
养活孩子，
都很值得尊重。
真的，
只要说老公不拖后腿，
不欠账，
我在外面花天酒地，
不乱花钱，
我就要把这个钱管起来，
她挣多少我管起来，
你要花多少，
合理的情况下咱就花。
但是那种打肿脸充胖子，
帮这个还债，
帮这个还债的事儿的话，
咱作为女人就得有主意，
就得有定力，
明白是什么意思吗？
什么叫有主意，
什么叫有定力，
我得先把我自己的日子。
过好了，
我才有可能啊，
帮惦记着这个，
关心着那个，
在我的日子过得不好的时候，
我这个脸不值钱，
我能求婆婆，
我就求婆婆，
婆婆能给我带孩子，
我暂时不用给她钱，
我这张脸不要了，
我就跟她说这个话。
只有当我自己的日子过顺了，
慢慢慢慢有点存款了，
你才能够想想，
哎，
我还能帮衬上谁啊？
你现在都这个样子，
你帮谁？
记得点赞关注哦。